i have been intermittent fasting with a
16 8 ratio on and off for about three
years now but i recently decided that it
was time to take it to the next level
and try a more difficult challenge i
recently did a no technology challenge
for two weeks and i thought it was the
perfect time to work on just
strengthening my mind and my body in all
sorts of ways and just have a greater
focus on improving habits which i
believe to be the building blocks of our
lives so what i have done is i have
fasted for 24 to 36 hours weekly for six
weeks and actually it's a little bit
more than that but the challenge was for
six weeks so that's what we're gonna
call it but i'm first gonna be talking
about what intermittent fasting is and
if you're already familiar then i'll
just time stamp it so you can skip past
that section but i'm gonna be telling
you about what i experienced the
struggles that i had how i coped the
lessons that i've learned and also share
some of the negative side effects that i
experienced because i feel like some
people don't want to talk about the
negative aspects of intermittent fasting
prolonged fasting can actually be
harmful under certain situations and for
certain people i am not a doctor i'm not
giving you medical advice i'm only
sharing with you my experience so please
become knowledgeable about fasting if
you are going to start and speak to a
health professional to see if it's right
for you but before we begin if you like
this video and find it helpful please
give it a thumbs up and help support my
channel and if you don't like it by all
means thumbs it down but please give me
some feedback in the comments so that i
know what to work on okay let's get
started in my video my five new healthy
habits i shared with you why i started
intermittent fasting what i liked about
it as well as the benefits that it has
on both a physical and a mental level
but for those of you who aren't familiar
with intermittent fasting it's not what
i consider to be a diet but rather a
lifestyle where basically you eat during
a certain time frame and you stop eating
during a certain time by many it is
considered an amazing way to lose weight
and it's actually how i did get
introduced to intermittent fasting about
three years ago as i was struggling to
lose my last few pounds of baby weight
but besides helping to manage your
weight and boost your metabolism it has
also been shown to have lots of other
great benefits such as decreased
inflammation decreased bloating
increased energy regulation of insulin
levels slowed aging through the increase
of growth hormone and a fancy term
called autophagy which is what i was
aiming for it's basically what i like to
call clean up mode so let me explain
this fancy term your cells are very hard
working and when you're constantly
eating your body is constantly focusing
on digestive processes but when you stop
eating for an extended period of time
your cells don't just sit back and take
a break they go into cleanup mode or
autophagy which basically means
self-eating basically they start
breaking down the old non-functioning
cells and all the toxic junk that you've
accumulated throughout the years the
best way that i can describe this for
you to have a visual is if you picture
having a bruise on your arm you have
this bruise and then magically within a
few days it's gone right well it's not
really magic your body actually sent
cells to that area to break down those
non-functioning junky cells and get rid
of them and then within a few days it's
gone well prolonged fasting works in a
similar way and this is what i was going
for and that's why i did an extended
fast now 24 hours was kind of like my
bare minimum but i know that the longer
the better the more cleanup you get and
so my longest fast was actually 40 hours
but i also did two 36 hour fast i
remember that when i first tried
intermittent fasting i was introduced to
it as a 16 8 and actually i had realized
that i met several people who did fast
in this way basically what that means is
they ate for eight hours throughout the
day and they stopped eating for six
hours and i realized that i didn't want
to begin that fast because for me that
was a drastic change i had never done
something like that before if i got
hungry at 12 in the morning i ate at 12
in the morning and so i wanted to focus
on building the habit instead of just
focusing on the numbers so initially for
me i started 12 12 and then i progressed
two more hours and then i finally
progressed to 16. however i noticed that
a lot of people what they do is they
skip breakfast and then that's how they
fast basically maybe something like 12
noon to 8 p.m but for me lattes are my
thing y'all like that gets me out of the
bed like yes latte time for me having
the ability to eat breakfast is very
motivating to get me out of the bed
early in the morning five-ish and so i
wanted to do something that i would
stick with rather than what everybody
else was doing and that's one thing that
i would recommend to you is if you do
want to do intermittent fasting whether
it's prolonged or shortened do something
that works for you that you will stick
with not just because this is the right
way to do it and another reason that i
personally prefer to skip dinner over
breakfast is because i find that this
helps me be more productive and make
better use of my time because the time
that i would have spent cooking
something prepping it eating it cleaning
up those dishes all that time is time
that i can spend cleaning up my house
and tidying up so that the day later
that next morning i can actually get up
and work on productive things instead of
procrastinating because there's a pile
of dishes and i
i need to clean the pile of dishes
instead of working out you know because
let's be honest sometimes we
procrastinate with productive things
that have to get done do you ever
procrastinate with productive things let
me know in the comments if it's just me
when i track my fast i use the app zero
it's completely free well it actually
does have like a paid version but y'all
i'm in it for the free stuff but it has
a lot of videos that you can watch and
articles that you can read to kind of
motivate you and educate you along the
way and help you with your fasting
journey you can also do challenges on it
you can set it to remind you when your
fast is over or when you're near over
and i also find that being able to place
the time and just forget about it and
hear that notification that oh you're
done it's just so much easier because i
can bet it and forget about it because i
can't imagine looking at the clock like
is it time to eat time to eat almost
time is it is it over is it almost over
so this has been a really nice tool for
me and i specifically like this app
versus other apps because i really like
the educational material that comes with
it because at least for me when i know
the why about why i'm doing things i'm
much more likely to stick with it so the
more i read articles up on this app the
more i saw the videos the educational
material the more i thought
oh i get it and so for me that just kind
of really dug home the point of why i
was doing what i was doing and it helped
me really keep this habit and a total
game changer for me is dave asprey's
insights and lessons that he describes
in his book fast this way i actually
didn't come across dave asprey until i
think the third week in which is a shame
because i had tried a 48 hour water only
fast and i made it to 40 hours
not because i was hungry but because i
just felt crappy i had a headache i felt
lethargic i i felt nauseous actually and
i decided that for me intermittent
fasting or extended fast was not about
just powering through the self-inflicted
suffering i wanted to feel good to have
energy that was the point for me at
least and so when i felt like this and i
was getting more irritable i decided no
it's time to stop so 40 hours was where
i cut it but then after that experience
i started to do more research to help
prevent that from happening again
because i don't want to do that type of
thing for six weeks and just power
through suffering so i learned that
there are certain things that i was
doing that was making it harder than it
had to be that i could drink black
coffee and drink tea and that not only
would that not negate the benefits of
fasting but that would actually help me
and there are certain supplements as
well that he talks about that you can
take to help negate some of those
negative side effects and i just liked
his overall view on fasting that he
doesn't think it has to be this
self-inflicted suffering experience that
really resonated with me because that
was never the goal and so i highly
recommend it if you are thinking of
doing extended fasts i can include the
link to the book in the description but
he does have a lot of youtube videos
that you can check out as well and they
are completely free99 now let's talk
about some of the ways that this
challenge has helped me the first way is
it has improved my eating habits and
this is
this is not something that i noticed it
was something that my husband actually
pointed out and truthfully it's a little
hard to talk about in the past i used to
just gobble up things immediately if i
really liked them if there was a slice
of cake i would eat a whole lot until i
felt sick until i felt full and bloated
because i couldn't just have a sliver
for the longest time i was like this i
didn't know why i just if if i had food
it had to be eaten right away and if i
liked something i had to eat until i was
bloated when i was a child i grew up
poor and
because of that and growing up poor i
guess i i had these values instilled
into me i don't know if subliminally or
people people actually did tell me these
things actually that if people give you
food you must clear your plate because
it's showing gratitude that they are
giving you their resources their
lifeline and growing a poor that is
literally they're giving you of their
life resources so you can eat and so if
you leave your plate halfway you're not
grateful for that and so i grew up
believing that that if you're given food
you must finish your meal
and also i guess i had this feeling of
if i like something i must eat it eat it
eat it because i don't know if i'm gonna
have that thing again um and this was
more of when i was a child because when
i grew up here in the united states we
had plenty of food that was never an
issue but i know that when i was a child
i could recognize that other children
had foods that i didn't have having
certain foods was a once in a few months
kind of a thing and so when i would go
to visit other people and they'd have
cereal it was like oh my gosh cereal i
could tease you it has a toy in the box
it was phenomenal and i
at that point i think is when i began to
just eat the moment i had the ability to
eat something that was not with not
normally in my home and i remember that
this is a child i never actually told my
grandma but i have a feeling she knows
when i would visit my grandma's house
and she had hot dogs which were not
something that we particularly had in
our home i would actually hide and i
actually would eat the whole pack of the
hot dogs and uh never explain who it was
i'm sure she knew who it was but so
these were the types of habits that i
had hoarding food eating it right away
here recently my husband actually
pointed out you know you eat slower and
when he said that it was like this light
bulb came out and i said you're right i
actually savor my food now and i also
noticed that one of the things that has
changed is that i now have the ability
to kind of stop where i love this
particular meal but you know what i'm
satiated i'm okay and i think it
specifically came out because sometimes
i experienced
bloating
immediately after or just this feeling
of fullness and nausea if i ate too much
after having a long fast so that's one
thing is i had to start eating slowly
and leaner meals so that i wouldn't
experience those side effects and so
having done that routinely and
repetitively i didn't realize this has
changed in me i'm embarrassed to admit
that but i think that a lot of people
can resonate with that especially if
you've had emotional struggles with
eating where you just eat when you're
anxious because that can happen you know
when you're sad and this really helped
me also in a way that it helped me make
better choices of the foods that i was
eating because if i only have this
certain time to eat
or if i'm doing this hard work of not
eating for this extended period of time
i didn't just do all this work for
nothing it's kind of the way that i
thought about it and so it has helped me
make better choices of the way that i
eat and having a healthier relationship
with food and then also helping remove
that guilt because you know what it's
okay if i do have some cake and not to
really feel guilt and attack myself for
the things that i am eating but rather
just overall make healthier choices to
nourish my body so also another thing
that i really liked is that when i'm
fasting i don't feel bloated i just feel
good i have more energy i just i feel
light in a way it's odd to explain i
have more time to really do other things
and focus my productive energy on other
things and actually contrary to what
many might believe working out when
you're in a fasted state is really good
for you it can help you actually build
muscle rather than lose muscle so just
overall it felt really good too fast
after i kind of learned that i didn't
have to torture myself and also just
really paying attention to my hydration
and making sure that i was well hydrated
as well to make sure that i didn't
develop headaches so now let's talk
about some of the difficulties of
fasting and i specifically want to
address hunger because i think that's
like the number one thing that people
worry about when they want to do fasting
or start off with fasting is i'm going
to be hungry all the time or i'm going
to get hungrier and hungrier and
hungrier and actually contrary to what
many people would believe that's not the
case so hunger actually comes in waves
because of hormones and specifically a
hormone called ghrelin so your body is
actually very smart and it learns your
patterns when you eat during specific
times let's say you eat your breakfast
lunch and your dinner your body over
time has actually learned these habits
and your hormones spike they go up and
they go down and because i've actually
done the shorter fast for a long time
before doing this challenge i've i had
come to already learn that and
experience that for myself that if i
just focus on a project or do a workout
or do something while i'm hungry it will
go away it doesn't usually last very
long really it's not that you're going
to be hungry all the time it's not that
you're going to get hungrier and
hungrier this is actually something that
you can just kind of learn to maneuver
and the more you can recognize it and
practice it the easier it gets so i i
would really recommend doing shorter
fasts before doing something like this
because i think more than anything it
was more of a mental challenge because
there's definitely a degree of fomo that
comes with it especially these longer
challenges of oh my gosh they're eating
this wonderful meal and i can't share it
and there's that feeling of i'm missing
out i'm missing out on that food that
they're eating that i can't eat or the
fear of when am i going to be able to
eat again and for anybody that has ever
had the experience of actually going
hungry where having food is not an
option there's definitely an aspect of
fear and so being able to practice that
in a controlled environment where you're
the boss where you could stop if you
wanted to i think really can help to
strengthen your mind and so more than
anything this challenge has been more of
a mental spiritual challenge you don't
necessarily have to do
fasting as a spiritual practice but i
think it is a huge component and so it's
just been interesting all the lessons
that i have learned the things that i've
learned about myself and the eating
habits that i had before that i had
never really noticed overall i think
this was a great experience and i think
one thing that can actually be really
helpful as well
a tip that i'd have for you is to let
the people around you know about what
you're doing and why you're doing it
because if they know that your purpose
is to help your body
maybe they won't be inclined to surprise
you with food or cook something because
i know for me
if my husband cooks something i think
it's really special i find it as an act
of love and so i feel rude to not eat
and so i actually let him know hey i'm
going to fast today so that he would
have kind of that warning like don't be
offering me food because i'm not going
to eat it and that really helped so that
would be a tip that i'd have for you is
to have an accountability partner or
just let the people around you know i
think the number one tip that i'd have
is if you are thinking of having an
extended pass is to schedule it during a
time that it will be
easy i guess if you can consider it easy
to avoid food for me what i did was i
did it kind of like evening time the day
before and then the next day i would be
working and so it would be hard to
actually have food because for me i'm a
home nurse anyway so if i ate it would
mean i would either pack my lunch or i'd
go to a restaurant physically and get
food and i don't ever do that anyway so
the only thing that i had to do was just
not pack a lunch and that would mean
that i'd have no temptation and because
i'm a home nurse it actually makes it
easier because i don't have other people
offering me food either there's no
co-workers there's no break time or
anything like that so for you if you are
thinking about this i would say just
think about your time wisely because it
really makes a big difference overall i
think this experience has been great um
i don't think that i would be doing it
on a weekly basis but i do definitely
see myself doing it again later on like
every couple of weeks or something like
that because i do find it as a reset
period for my body i feel better and
just overall the psychological aspects
that come with eating because i think
our relationship to food should not be
that a fear should not be that of guilt
or anxiety and it can really help to to
free you from that when you do
intermittent fasting either on a regular
basis or extended pass kind of
periodically so at least for me it was
very helpful truthfully this whole
challenge has been a surprise i honestly
expected that i'd be telling you more
physical results like that my eczema is
healed and no not really i still have it
so it shows you that i still have
inflammation however i do still see
fasting as a part of my life probably
not 24 hours every single week but i do
still see it in my future so hopefully
sharing my experience has been helpful
for you and that i haven't rambled too
much i'm sorry if i've rambled there's
just so much to be said about this topic
but if it's been helpful in any way
please give it a thumbs up and help
support my channel and let me know what
challenges you'd like to see me try i
thank you for watching and i can't wait
to hear from you bye
you